I think that you know drama and comedy
share a wall for sure they're they're
adjacent yeah the wonderful Sarah
Silverman from I smile back how you
doing I'm great how you doing and I was
just telling you that I saw this film
back at Sundance does it feel like a
really long road for this movie yeah but
I mean I can't believe I think we're all
like shocked it that it happened yeah
got made and we did it it's brilliant
it's kind of maybe that is so
heartbreaking and so full of emotion and
you are incredible was it a challenge
for you to take on this role I imagine
emotionally it must have been it was it
was yeah why don't you stop taking your
meds you're making me fat that's books
chairs she'd rather be insane
lady rise and shine beautiful what did
you relate to the most with your
character I have experience with
depression and I understand the feeling
of letting it swallow you up and even
being drawn to letting it swallow you up
what people get from it is just so
completely dependent on their own life
experience yeah you know some people
might have empathy for her compassion
and you know other people will probably
be like [ __ ] and her you know
firstworldproblems centers me I like
movies or stuff that where you walk away
and you completely disagree with your
friends on what you both saw oh
definitely are you someone who reads
reviews it's been getting really good
reviews and it's yeah yeah I look at it
yeah I'm not a big reader but skim it
for keywords yeah well it's all been
good so far and i highly recommend that
Sarah Silverman thank you so much for
joining so much and make sure you see I
smile back and buy a tickets on fandango
ah gillette my jasmine hey
you